you were hanging out being a musician
and you were friends with Ethan Hawke
and he got was he directing a movie he
was in the movie reality bites right he
was starring in it was the director
still I was a director and he was in it
and and Ethan asked me for a copy of one
of the songs that I was playing out at
my shows a lot called stay right and you
were just like an unsigned artist or
somebody starting out with a musical
career yeah actually there were some
record companies interested in college
but they weren't quite I wasn't signed
to a record deal okay
so Ethan Close is a friend of hers likes
the song stay and says to Ben Stiller
you put this on the soundtrack for the
movie reality bites when Ben Stiller
heard your song he right away say I've
got to have this on my soundtrack or was
he like kind of like I don't know I
don't know I think he liked it and
because I wasn't signed or any kind of
record company we were they were able to
make a deal with me to put the song in
the movie and put the entire song and
the credits of the movie and then all of
a sudden when the songs on the
soundtrack this radio station down in
Houston starts playing stay on the radio
and then other stations started playing
it and all of a sudden I was an unsigned
artist with a song going up the charts
and when my song was number one that's
when I was making my record deal this is
a song that holds up it's not it holds
up I mean it's still relevant today yeah
it's it's it's about arguments with a
boyfriend so we just written about Ethan
Hawke no it wasn't this is you trying to
tell some guy to stay
it's that argument it's like you know
you're only here at the lyric is I only
hear what I want to and it's the
argument back and forth you know the
person saying you're naive you're this
or that you're trying to be too clever
it's criticizing you and yet he's
telling you to stay yeah because you but
but that's what happens in a strong
relationship you have to be able to
argue I think so here's the song stay
and just think back to Lisa's life she's
hanging out nosey some hog this song
gets on the soundtrack song goes to
number one and now every record company
in the country wants her I love that
story here we go
[Music]
you say I only hear what I want you
[Music]
you say I talk so of a time so
and I thought don't belong now that I
know that I did something wrong
[Music]
this
[Music]
you say I only hear what I want to a
don't listen heart don't pay attention
to the distance it's running do anyone
anywhere don't
if you really care
no-no-no
I turn the radio on to the radio
and this one was saying my song rubbers
in love and the others run away member
is crying cuz the other will stay
[Music]
really
well this is not that they better crumb
but I'm thrown
[Music]
I'm sure you try to tell me that I'm
clever but that won't take me anyhow or
anywhere with you
[Music]
I thought that I was strong though I but
hey I can leave I can leave now I know
that I was wrong miss you
[Music]
you said you call me cuz you want me and
one day let me go you try to give away
but keep me cuz you know you're just so
scared
and you say
[Music]
see
[Music]
you say I only hear what I want to
[Music]